Guu wrote number sucks I'm so excited
about this one you guys first I just
want to talk about a few updates on the
channel I've got a huge project going on
right now that's why this video kind of
took forever I've got a really cool
video coming in the works all about the
trending tab so get excited about that a
little birdie told me y'all have been
waiting awhile for this one so I'm sorry
about that
here it finally is this is the fake guru
that they don't want you to know about
so who am I talking about well I'm
talking of course about the great Kevin
Trudeau Kevin Trudeau if you don't know
is a man a classy man he's one of the
great con artists that you know we just
don't have a lot of anymore there's a
bunch of small fries and that's who you
we usually cover but Kevin Trudeau was
kind of one of the last great con men
you know the guy who doesn't just con
once once and done he cons over his
entire life okay let's talk about it
so Kevin Trudeau was a pitchman he was
an infomercial guy and he would make
wild claims about some products that he
would sell so here's here's an example
here's the basic claim of the school
that there are natural non-drug and
non-surgical ways to prevent and cure
virtually every disease virtually every
one cancer heart disease diabetes herpes
the list goes on animal you got it we'll
solve it with the natural cures they
don't want you to know about so that
that's what of his infomercials but he's
done a lot more than that he also did
here's some of the products that he's
sold in the past the natural cure is
right in here we bought some of the
things the book recommends like this
electromagnetic
eliminate it's supposed to ward off
migrants this magnetic mattress pad will
cure multiple sclerosis this trampoline
will help cure depression while wearing
white will improve your mood and help
prevent disease this guy's amazing so he
he sells he sells all the stuff and then
basically promises the world he didn't
just do infomercials about books he
started as just a traditional
infomercial guy like he would sell this
thing called mega memory which
supposedly made you remember everything
you ever ever heard yes you can have a
photographic memory the impact of course
is so powerful now my memory is 700
percent more powerful than I was before
if you have not ordered the mega memory
program yet I urge you order now he sold
this band that eliminated pain m'angil
remedy you can put on come on on the
skin it will imprint of pain forever our
greatest pain will go away there is a
natural herbal supplement that the Asian
Diabetes Association has called the
final cure for diabetes this guy sells
it man you can kind of feel it too how
good of a Salesman he is you almost like
want to believe him even it even if you
know he's wrong just watching some of
his videos you just feel like oh that's
good my sugar might have said he just
has confidence he's got the legendary
confidence of a great conman and yeah he
sold that he sold this thing that you
put on your hand and it was supposed to
eliminate all arthritis pain he sought a
cream that was supposed to cure all your
baldness I mean this guy's done it all
and every time he would do it he would
get away with it for like two years make
a few million dollars and then heat the
FTC would get on him the Federal Trade
Commission would get on him and issue
consent orders on him and tell him look
you got to stop promising these
ridiculous claims right and so he's like
he'd be like alright I'll settle out of
court he so by settling he would never
plead guilty so no one would ever be
able to say you've gotten you've been
proven guilty by this stuff and he would
use that as a way to sort of say that oh
no no I'm not guilty I I we had a
settlement and they had to drop all the
charges well they didn't drop them right
they settled they dropped the charges
there's a settlement
Elmen is different from dropping the
charges a settlement you paid how was he
different you paid two million dollars
no they didn't they equip me wait how's
it different well you you paid two
million dollars yeah but they didn't
charge me they didn't charge me it just
paid two million dollars to settle this
guy's amazing he's uh he's got all the I
don't know the juno said qua of a great
of a great con man so he kept dodging
things like this right for a while and
then finally he was told as you just
heard you cannot do any more
informations of products so what does
Kevin Trudeau do not to be deterred by
this new consent order he decides that
instead of doing that instead of
listening he's gonna start writing books
and that's where the infamous weight
loss cures they don't want you to know
about and other book titles come from
now if you don't know about weight loss
cures that they don't they don't want
you to know about is the title of it it
sold almost a million copies which in
book terms is like way past bestseller
things can become bestsellers at like
20,000 bucks sold this sold a million
copies and you know what he said he said
you can eat anything you want on this
diet all you've got to do is get
injections of this thing called HCG it
wasn't without its critics namely the
people who actually tried it out so
here's here's one such story this is the
result of eating too much low I'm not
pregnant
this is what you get after you finish
the HCG and go back you did before 57
pounds head up then my lowest injection
weight this is proof
can it for dirt lie in his book the
weight loss cure that I wanted to know
about you stated that you can eat
anything you want can you finish the HCG
cycles a weight back on obviously the
man wide okay I don't know what that
beatboxing was in the background but
yeah I totally made it up totally made
it up the guy is such a scam artist and
after that the FTC said because he said
that and he misled so many people healed
$37,000 37 million sorry 37 million
dollars and that's where things got
really nasty so at that point people
that's when people like Jake Tapper
called him out and he got really
defensive over the medicine that
actually backed up some of his claims
the University of Calgary has 25 years
of research and I'm really glad you
brought it up because diabetes can be if
not completely cured wiped out in
America dramatically reduced by this
herbal combination we call the
University of Calgary and I'm gonna read
you exactly what they say there have
been no human studies conducted at the
University of Calgary in the past 20
years on herbal remedies for diabetes
okay shocked in the main fact that up
Vegh that have lodges
watch his face as he realizes that he
got caught and wiped out in America
dramatically reduced by this herbal
combination we called the University of
Calgary and I'm gonna read you exactly
what they say they're a bit no look at
the Bateman studies process he acted at
the University of Calgary in the past 20
years on herbal remedies for diabetes
okay shocked and amazed cuz I was just
physically in an office in Connecticut
yesterday where I had the stack of this
thick and I'll have to send it to you he
never did send that stack or any studies
from the University of Calgary so he got
fined 37 million dollars for one of his
one of his books being wrong because he
had to you know refund some of the money
and he said he didn't have it and this
is where he finally got caught our boy
got caught and this is a lesson to all
you fake gurus out there who haven't
been caught yet there's a lot of you
really the main reason that he got
caught was just because he was so
successful okay let's start there your
average small-fry fake guru is never
needed caught because the FTC has to
I used a ton of time to bring these guys
down I mean it took like 18 years to
bring down Kevin Trudeau and he was like
at the top of the list of fake gurus so
that's kind of the thing that's the
sucky thing is that you're probably not
gonna get caught but let's say you are
at the top of the food chain here's how
you don't go to jail you have money at
the end of the day Kevin Trudeau his
problem was not because he actually got
caught and like got found guilty he
really got put in jail in the end
because he couldn't pay the fines of his
one of his like settlement decrees right
they told him to to pay 37 million
dollars he said he didn't have it they
said okay well you can't own any assets
till you pay us back to which he moved
to Italy and started living off some
shell corporations and finally he got
caught because it's not such a smart
idea so yeah a moment of silence for our
for our fake guru the best fake guru
probably America has ever seen just one
of the few that gets caught I just like
talking about the stuff the the most
annoying thing is when people tell me
when I make a fake guru series they're
like well he hasn't been caught yet so
he's not guilty it's like there are
plenty of people who are vigorous that
got caught usually when people haven't
been caught yet it's because usually
they're too small they're too much
small-time for the for the government to
step in and actually intervene so
alright that's the fake guru they don't
want you to know about I will be back
with another one soon thanks for all
your requests you guys have given me a
lot of ideas for the next fake gurus
keep them coming I love it and yeah okay
we'll keep well keep exposing these bad
buys I need an ultrasonic song
[Music]
oh yeah yeah yeah let's try it let's try
something eat get gonna fake then you
better prepare for cutting bait to come
after you get gonna fake ever coming
back to come happy eating gonna fake
fake